Determinar si las parejas ordenadas
3,5 y 1,-7
son soluciones a la desigualdad "5x" menos "3y"
mayor o igual que 25
ok... mayor o igual que 25,
así que, lo que vamos a intentar
hacer, es que a partir de esta...
de estos pares... de este par de puntos,
vamos a ver qué pasa cuando lo sustituimos en esta desigualdad,
y ver si la satisface o no.
Entonces primero vamos
a intentar con el 3,5
así que ponemos...
vamos a poner...
vamos a sustituir
y ponemos 5 por "x" que en este caso es 3,
en este caso es 3...
déjenme hacerlo en otro color...
ok, 5 por 3
5 por 3 menos 3 por...
y ahora sustituimos la "y"
que en este caso es, 5
así que tenemos 3 por 5
y vamos a ver si
esto es mayor o igual que 25 ¿ok?
no sabemos,
así que 5 por 3 es 15,
menos 3 por 5 son 15 también,
y esto vamos a ver si es mayor o igual que 25,
y le ponemos signo de interrogación, porque no sabemos si esto es cierto,
pero bueno 15 menos 15 = 0
y esto será mayor o igual que 25
y esto no es cierto ¿verdad?
esto realmente...
en realidad 0 es menor que 25
así que esto no es cierto, así que,
esta pareja ordenada
no es solución a la desigualdad,
no es solución...
no es solución, ¿ok?
simplemente sustituimos en la ecuación
o en la desigualdad
y vemos que no se cumple la desigualdad.
Ahora vamos a intentar con
el otro punto con el 1,-7
entonces 5 por "x", que en este caso es 1 menos 3
por "y" que es -7
ok, y esto será mayor o igual que 25
otra vez, no sabemos, vamos a ver,
5 por 1 es 5 y -3 por -7 son más 21
es decir menos, -21,
vamos a hacerlo por pasos
y queremos ver si es mayor o igual que 25,
ahora 5 más 21,
que es menos por menos da más
y esto será mayor o igual que 25
bueno, 5 más 21 son 26
y que en efecto es mayor o igual que 25
ok, así que esto funciona,
funciona para este punto
y este punto es solución.
Ya... ya hemos visto un poquito de
cómo visualizar esto,
vamos a graficar la desigualdad,
no vamos a...
no quiero mostrarles exactamente cómo voy a hacer esto, de una forma muy rigurosa,
solo quiero que lo visualicen muy bien.
Entonces, vamos a ponerlo esto en...
déjenme usar otro color...
5... dije otro color, creo que el día de hoy
tengo problemas cambiando colores.
Tenemos "5x" menos "3y"
mayor o igual que 25
y lo que quiero hacer es cambiar esto en la forma pendiente ordenada al origen
muy bien entonces resto "5x" de ambos lados
y tengo "-3y" mayor o igual que "-5x" más 25
ok, eso fue restando "5x" de ambos lados, ok,
y ahora vamos a dividir ambos lados de la desigualdad
o... sí, de la desigualdad por -3, ok.
Entonces cuando dividimos o multiplicamos una desigualdad por un número negativo
el signo de la desigualdad cambia de sentido ¿verdad?
entonces tendremos "y" menor o igual que menos 5 entre menos 3 simplemente es 5 tercios por "x"
y luego 25 entre -3 es -25/3.
Muy bien,
entonces si vamos a graficar esto
esta es la expresión de una desigualdad
que es menor o igual que 5/3 por "x"
menos 25/3,
entonces, si vamos a graficar esto,
ok, vamos a hacerlo a groso modo en una
pequeña gráfica
solo para visualizar un poco,
de qué estamos hablando
así que la intersección con el eje "y"
es -25/3
ok, que eso es un poquito más que 8...
ok, aquí está el 8 y un poquito más,
aquí está la intersección
ok, con -25/3
y tiene una pendiente de 5/3
eso quiere decir que por cada
3 que avanzó en la dirección "x"
aumenta 5 en la dirección "y"...
en la dirección vertical así que,
esta línea se vería algo así,
ok,
más o menos a grosso modo
la línea se vería de esta forma,
ok
¿qué pasaría si "y" es igual
a 5/3  de  "x" -25/3?
Ok, pero aquí tenemos
una desigualdad menor o igual
ok, entonces para cualquier "x" la "y"
que satisface son todos estos valores
por ejemplo fijándonos en una "x"
ok,
fijándonos en esta "x" particular
todas las "y" que satisfacen la solución,
son toda esta área de aquí abajo, ok
es las "y" menores o iguales que esta línea
y por supuesto incluimos la línea porque tenemos la posibilidad de que sea igual ¿verdad?
ok, si no este, pondríamos la línea punteada,
ahora vamos a ver si estos puntos están,
por ejemplo empezamos con el 3,5
ok, entonces subimos ahora aquí 5
y aquí está el 3,5
que como podemos ver está
fuera de la región que hemos sombreado.
Ahora el 1,-7 ese está casi dentro de
la línea ¿verdad?
pero está en esta región,
ok
así que,
si está justo en esta en este lugar
está en el conjunto en el área que
es el conjunto de la solución ¿verdad?
Espero que esto te haya dado mucho
sentido de cómo visualizar estas desigualdades.